the unfortunate fact about physics is
the takeoff is easier than the landing
yes yes and you mentioned Starship one
of the incredible engineering Feats that
you get to see is the reusable rockets
that take off but they land and they
land uh using control and they do so
perfectly and sometimes when it's
synchronous it's just it's beautiful to
see and then with Starship you see the
the Chopsticks that catch the ship I
mean there's just so much incredible
engineer but you mentioned uh Starships
is somehow helpful here so what's your
hope with Starship what kind of science
might it enable possibly there's two
things I mean it's the launch cost
itself which is hopefully going to mean
per kilogram it's going to dramatically
reduce the cost of its the sort of the
level even if it's a factor of 10 higher
than what Elon originally promised this
is going to be a revolution for the cost
to Launch that means you could do all
sorts of things you could launch
um large telescopes which could be
basically like jwst but you don't even
have to fold them up jwst had this whole
issue with a design that it's six and a
half meters across and so you have to
there's no fuselage which is that large
at the time there is four wasn't large
enough for that and so they had to fold
it up into this kind of complicated
origami and so a large part of the cost
was figuring out how to fold it up
testing that it unfolded correctly
repeated testing and you know there was
something like 130 fail points or
something during this unfolding
mechanism and so all of us were holding
our breath during that process but if
you have the ability to Just Launch in
an arbitrarily large masses at least
comparatively compared to jbst and very
large mirrors into space you can more or
less repurpose ground-based mirrors the
Hubble Space Telescope mirror and the
jbsd mirrors are designed to be
extremely lightweight and that increased
their cost significantly they have this
kind of any comb design on the back to
try and minimize the the weight if you
don't really care about weight because
it's so cheap then you could just
literally grab many of the existing
ground-based mirrors across tuskers
across the world four meter five meter
mirrors and just pretty much attach them
to a chassis and have your own
space-based telescope
um I think the Breakthrough foundation
for instance uh is an entity that has
been interested in doing this sort of
thing and so that raises the prospects
of having not just one wst that just you
know wst is a fantastic resource but
it's split between all of us
cosmologists star formation astronomers
those of us studying exoplans those of
us wanting to study you know the ultra
deep fields and the origin of the first
galaxies the expansion rate of the
universe everyone has to share this
resource but we could potentially each
have you know one jwst each that is uh
maybe just studying a handful of the
brightest exoplanet stars and measuring
their atmospheres this is important
because if you we talked about this
plant trappist-1a earlier
that planet if dwc started it and tried
to look for buyer signatures by which I
mean oxygen
nitrous oxide methane it would take it
of order of 200 transits to get even a
very marginal what we call two and a
half Sigma detection of those which
basically nobody would believe with with
that and 100 transits I mean this thing
transits once every six days so you're
talking about sort of four years of
staring at the same star with one
telescope there'd be some breaks but
it'd be hard to schedule much else
because you'll have to continuously
catch each one of these transits to
build up your signal to noise
and so JBC is never going to do that in
principle technically wst could
technically have the capability of just
about detecting a buyer signature on an
Earth-like planet around around a
non-sung-like star but still
impressively we have basically the
technologists do that but we simply
cannot dedicate all of its time
practically to that one resource and so
Starship opens up opportunities like
that of mass producing these kinds of
telescopes which will allow us to survey
for life in the universe which of course
is one of the grand goals of astronomy